these are the last moments of tamir  rice's life a woman calling the police  says twice she thinks the gun he's  carrying is fake it was a pellet gun  then she's  what asked he look like  he has a camouflage shadow  is he black or white  he has a gray  gray coat with black sleeves and great  pants  then the police arrived  officers say they ordered tamir three  times to put his hands up before  shooting  the police say they were just doing  their job  we've got two officers that were  out there protecting the public that  just had to uh you know  do something that nobody wants to do  tamir's death has added new fuel to the  anger many in the u.s are feeling over  the treatment of african americans by  the authorities